this program is intended for people who
are senior enough that they have that
they they're seasoned they've had a lot
of experience they've worked with other
people they've been involved with teams
they've they've grown a lot in their
jobs and they probably have one or two
promotions that they can make so that
they can move up one or two levels from
where they are and and the organization
has high expectations for how useful
that they will be in the future so when
you put them into this environment and
they get this exposure to other talented
people those are the kind of people that
when they come back to your company will
benefit the most and will benefit the
company the most
one of the things that people really
love is the entrepreneurial part of the
program where actual venture capitalists
come in and and your peers appraise your
ideas for about a new product you have
to put together a whole idea for
developing a new product and put
together a presentation and a business
plan for it presented to the group and
then get rated by VCS and get rated by
your peers everybody raves about that
part of the program as being something
that brought out a lot of creativity a
lot of conflict too but a lot of a lot
of creativity and and made good use of
the talents that were in the room so
people seem to like that a lot and then
as I said because there's a lot of
academic breath people usually learn
some aspect of technology the technology
industry or just business in general
that they may have missed in their prior
life
when we send people to this program they
come for two weeks and they come back
quite transformed in terms of how they
look at business so that's that's a very
time efficient to use of talented
resource
because the program in invites such a
variety of enrollees and from different
kinds of companies some of them are
software companies some of them are
hardware companies some of them are
cloud companies and and it's just or a
variety of different backgrounds so you
get this this wonderful mix and that I
think not only adds to the educational
experience it also gives you a chance to
meet people you wouldn't otherwise me to
form connections to people you otherwise
might not form a connection to and that
gives you a networking opportunity so
going forward these are people that you
now know that can help you in your
career or they might be people that you
want to call up and ask a typical
question to in the future so I think if
it's a way to form connections you
otherwise wouldn't get to form so easily
I would describe it as a high-impact
educational program that will make
employees grateful that they went and
will return a more valuable employee to
the company
you